So it's probably not obvious why this
would be true, but this is the thing
that we're claiming, and I want to at
least make it clear what we're claiming.
The claim is that any value function at
any given step of value iteration can be
represented finitely as just a maximum
over a bunch of linear functions.
Each linear function can handle
an infinite number of inputs.
Right?
And that is not so
surprising if a linear
functions can do that.
But what is cool is we don't actually
have to represent the value for
each possible belief state b.
Instead, we just throw all these linear
functions into a bag, gamma sub t.
And then when we want
to know the value for
a given belief state b, we compute
all the linear function values and
just take whichever one is
the highest at that point.
>> Okay.
I mean I guess that that
makes sense in the abstract.
I guess the only thing that I don't yet
get is exactly where gamma comes from.
>> Yes,
that's what we have to step through.
And that is not at all obvious,
I think, but it is very
elegant that it all works out.
And this was originally shown
by a fellow named Sondik and
once you see it, it's maybe not so
hard to see, but I don't know how
he got here in the first place.
>> It's, to me,
not all readily apparent, but
once you see things this way,
it gives you a very powerful way to work
with these infinite-sized state spaces.
You just have to take operations
on bags of vectors and
so it ends up all being finite.